Russian President Vladimir Putin said
that Moscow would suspend its
participation in the last remaining
major nuclear arms control treaty
between the U.S and Russia the new start
treaty
[Music]
treaty is and what Russia's suspension
means for Global nuclear arms control
the new start meaning new strategic
armed reduction treaty was signed in
Prague in 2010 by former president
Barack Obama and former Russian
president Dimitri mediadev
it was an extension to start one which
was signed in 1991. this was a way to
try to reset relations between Russia
and the US after the Cold War the
agreement was important because these
two countries hold approximately 90
percent of the world's nuclear weapons
so The Pact was created to make sure
this Arsenal was controlled
the treaty limits the number of
strategic nuclear warheads that can be
deployed by either Russia or the US to
1550 and allows both sides to inspect
each other's nuclear facilities
Vladimir Putin said it was time to
suspend this deal because Russia fills
the U.S has not abided by the agreement
by not allowing Russian inspectors on
U.S nuclear sites the U.S said it is
Russia that is blocking on-site
inspections NATO Secretary General urge
Vladimir Putin to reconsider the
suspension we have to remember that this
is one of the last major Arms Control
agreements we have the foreign Ministry
has said following Mr Putin's
announcement that Russia would continue
to observe the limits on the number of
nuclear warheads it can deploy under the
treaty and it also said that Russia
would continue to notify the U.S when it
plans to test launch intercontinental
ballistic missiles and submarine launch
ballistic missiles
we'll be watching carefully
to see what Russia actually does we'll
of course make sure that in any event we
are postured appropriately for the
security of our own country and and that
of our allies
this suspension means that the U.S will
lose access to inspect some of Russia's
nuclear facilities and it's worrisome
because what Russia is planning whatever
that is it could become more shrouded in
secrecy but moreover it calls into
question whether or not this agreement
to control nuclear weapons can actually
last now
China for example has indicated that it
wants to build a large nuclear Arsenal
North Korea as we know has been testing
intercontinental ballistic missiles and
there's also concern among Western
officials that Iran might actually be
close to making bomb grade nuclear fuel
the journal spoke to the director of the
pro Kremlin Institute for political
studies who said that if Washington
doesn't listen to Moscow now Putin May
officially withdraw from the treaty and
if that happens we could expect a change
that would reduce the US's nuclear
security